welcome to this game back door 13 no
I've not played against this guy check
the bogo yeah I can transpose to the
NIMS oh maybe do that this line okay
let's see what he is playing okay my
knowledge there's not very thorough I
looked at a number of lines here for
black and with white I really really
only no fragments of some nights I'll be
interesting to see what he chooses I
have knight c6 in my project yeah I can
check you now Jack if you want to play
d5 you have to have to catch the first
normally or is it is it not that bad he
has those Queen 27 tricks Quinn to d7
remarkable if I check here can I somehow
keep my keep the material let's try
Knight takes I have queen d for ya and
let's check this I can try hmm ok well
[ __ ] Bishop e3 it's not a bad move i
mean that that's that's that's clear
yeah let's do that let's do that
and I really don't know if I have have a
better continuation okay I can play
Bishop h3 now sister this is something
Queen takes Queen c6 check Queen back we
need some store I'm still killing his
castling rides might be Anna might be a
move now push up age three okay the
Queen will move somewhere to be seven
maybe it's not clear that I have gained
much okay probably this is better okay
can play c5 now I cannot I can take I
can still take maybe I could have played
okay let's not spend so long here c5 I
can still take d7 and win a porn with a
good position my plan is just rupee 1.e4
and he resigns the question is maybe I
couldn't play Bishop c5 to really
prevent any kind of move there the c5
IDM hmm
okay let's do that just I'm just
completely shutting down this idea they
still have rookie one and you for coming
25 in some cases but Queenie 6 is some
is holding
yeah just e-form is coming here I came I
can go if for now i'll start with rookie
one maybe start and luke t 1 and then he
fought this king will really never be
safe that's really no no way to get it
into safety if he takes it I'm wonder
what I'm doing actually I didn't
calculate that I just thought okay if i
open the position it must be great but i
didn't calculate the move did you form I
mean queen d 797 Bishop h3 rook covers
rookie for I should probably be a
witness is going to be in deadly pins I
don't see how he and pins there takes
checks rookie for it's a bit lame to
trade queens but if it wins it wins yeah
it does way back so let's do it hey I
wanted to check made of course but if
you if you win you should just play it
and and be be happy about it let's say
look the aid i have a pleasant choice i
can play Bishop e7 our OB should be six
one of those two all-rookie form not
sure rookie falls also pretty strong any
yeah this is this is this is quite
strong threatening would be seven or
Ruby phone away he goes King see 7s
rookie seven he will he will lose some
material ki f5s idea okay so do i have
to take on d7 first then okay it's not
even that clear take stakes I can check
on the area and then take on d7k check
that's a piece no is continuing yeah
okay only recently I managed to screw up
a game it was a complete black eyes I ok
but it didn't happen here it's also
really really easy now I can just invade
with the king yeah that's an opening a
disaster the move d5 was just too early
let's check there I think this is just
quite fine he can maybe take with the
pawn I mean I'm not sure Bishop CM Queen
c6 check it's not so clear to me yeah
any move here he has 94 I would have
played Bishop e3 I guess with the
similar ideas but this looks a bit maybe
this 4 C 5 may is a bit better than then
then the game that looked quite
convincing I think Queen c6 there's
queen before
my mouth 27 said threat and cakes yeah I
now now interesting their Bishop Atreus
I think it looks flashy but I don't know
if it's doing that much so I avoided
that computer wants to do this it's not
a bad idea of course trying to open like
that
really bad positioning okay but that
that cannot be bad am keeps a big edge
this this rookie one okay yeah I wanted
to stop c 5 I mean I wasn't totally sure
how convincing this is the head is very
good but check it's an end game now I
don't I don't want it endgame I just
want to make sure that the king is
staying in the center 44 and 40 for and
know if I it's all quite logical and 27
is probably easiest check now I could
have played that but check picks up the
bishop and here I could have taken on d7
with the bishop so but ok ok pieces the
pieces a piece that's totally totally
enough ok that was a decent game thanks
for watching